bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'actu
tour d'horizon de l'actualité locale en
une trentaine de minutes et on démarre
avec ses agents de la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy qui ont protesté ce vendredi
matin devant leur établissement
ils dénoncent leurs conditions de
travail et notamment les agressions qui
selon eux se multiplient war se banalise
en moins de dix jours par exemple ils
ont relevé une douzaine de collègues
blessés en coin selon eux la
surpopulation carcérale à ses agents on
regrette également un manque de soutien
de la part de leur direction ils
avancent que de nouveaux services ont
été créés comme un quartier de
semi-liberté sans que cela s'accompagne
de recrutements supplémentaires et que
les sanctions à l'encontre des détenus
violents ne sont pas suffisantes
on écoute en écoute pardon christophe
dubi son idée du syndicat ufap
on demande juste que de l'effectif parce
qu'on a beau dire si malheureusement on
manque beaucoup d'argent on est rappelé
en europe au fait on accumule les heures
supplémentaires la fatigue
automatiquement les argents elles
peuvent pas suivre
la cadence qui est la cadence des
journées des matins des maths et des
nuits qu'on effectue donc plus la
fatigue donc on manque aussi on demande
aussi un soutien la direction les
détenus au peu de sanctions
on demandait le maximum c'est à dire 30
jours de cul des deux quartiers
disciplinaires fermes alors qu'il ait
beaucoup de sursis il ya eu voilà il est
des détenus ont même pas peur de dd des
sanctions qui peuvent avoir un
administratif ou disciplinaires et selon
les syndicats la prison de bois d'arcy
compte aujourd'hui 8 199 détenus pour
500 places et de cent soixante douze
agents les syndicats ont été reçus dans
la matinée sans sortie dit il
content de cette rencontre ayant
l'assurance de leur chef d'établissement
que des sanctions plus importantes
seraient prises à l'encontre des détenus
violents
allez un autre mouvement de protestation
cette fois du côté des agents de la caf
la caisse d'allocations familiales ils
ont profité de la venue à la ministre de
la famille dominique bertinotti
c'était ce jeudi à mantes la jolie pour
faire entendre leur voix ils étaient
venus de l'ensemble du département pour
dénoncer hausses de charge du travail de
travail mauvaises conditions d'accueil
des allocataires ou encore plafonnement
des salaires et dominique bertinotti
elle de son côté a préféré noté des
améliorations survenues ces derniers
mois et appelle les syndicats à plus de
propositions écoute et nous ce qu'on
souhaite surtout dire madame bertinotti
mais qui ne recevra pas aujourd'hui
c'est tout simplement qu'on veut bien
d'accueil rénové on veut bien des locaux
tout neufs quand vous surtout du
personnel derrière les bureaux
c'est une initiative aussi qu'on a pris
qui s'est jamais passé à la caf des
yvelines de réunir aujourd'hui de
saint-quentin demande de
saint-germain-en-laye des collègues qui
viennent aujourd'hui dire à la ministre
ça suffit on peut plus travailler comme
ça voilà on peut avoir toujours plus
d'effectifs
on peut mettre toujours plus de moyens
c'est la solution je dirais la plus
facile aujourd'hui nous avons cette
exigence quand même nous sommes dans un
cadre budgétaire contraint de travailler
aussi bien voire même mieux et le fait
d'avoir de mettre du personnel là où
c'est le plus nécessaire c'est ça que
les syndicats doivent défendre et plaidé
et puis toujours du côté de l'emploi
cette annonce du ou du côté d'airbus
groupe à elancourt anciennement eads ce
site avec celui des mureaux serait
durement touché par les annonces de
suppressions de postes fait en début de
semaine l'entreprise veut améliorer sa
compétitivité dans le domaine de la
défense et de l'espace 5800 emplois vont
disparaître en europe dont à 720 prévu
dans les yvelines un plan de
restructuration qui devrait s'échelonner
jusqu'en 2017 alors un comité
extraordinaire d'entreprise s'est tenu
ce vendredi matin les syndicats disent
ne pas avoir obtenu de réponse à leur
question de réponse tout cas précise à
leurs questions notamment en ce qui
concerne ces suppressions de postes il
espère des avancées d'ici la mi février
et puis social encore l'annoncé de la
suppression de 684 poste s'est apprécié
par psa des reclassements sont attendus
mais 400 intérimaires vont voir leur
contrat prendre fin à la fin mars
le constructeur automobile a annoncé ce
jeudi vouloir supprimer une des deux
équipes dédiées à la production de la
208 les prévisions de production pour
2014 ne seraient pas bonnes selon la
direction 40 % de baisse par rapport à
l'an dernier et les syndicats craignent
eux à terme tout simplement la fermeture
du site de poissy et la délocalisation
de toute la production
allez on poursuit ce 7,8 actu très
chargée sur le plan social avec des
sourires cette fois c'était hier soir ce
jeudi soir avec l'inauguration du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines sur place anthony rech et
jonathan lui même le ruban est enfin
coupé par la ministre des sports valérie
fourneyron des compétitions peuvent
démarrer lors de l'inauguration du
vélodrome elles sont évidemment amical
mais elles n'en ont que le nom car à un
mois des championnats du monde en
colombie
les coureurs français entendent bien
marquer les esprits britannique
on est là pour ça ahmad c'est un masque
vous gagnez tout simplement le b
collègues - n'a vraiment pas de tout
gagner même si 5
sabine les bons hommes
logiquement leur médecin pour moi un peu
moins d'un mois après leur installation
les tricolores semblent déjà l'apport du
vélodrome au quotidien dans leur
préparation aux mondiaux d'équipement
bien on découvre la piste et tout
l'outil qu'on a à disposition pour aller
préparer ces jeux olympiques de rio
et c'est vraiment
toute la soirée les duels se sont
succédé entre nos bleus de france et les
sprinter britannique et carton plein
pour les tricolores qui se sont imposés
sur les six épreuves programmées qui
arrive vitesse individuelle et par
équipe et sous la clameur d'un vélodrome
plein c'est super on n'a vraiment pas
l'habitude surtout enfoncé gérer on a
plutôt l'habitude de faire des courses
ou ya aller les parents qui nous
encouragent donc la voir tout ce monde
et puis on a tous invités des amis de la
famille l'histoire retiendra que
françois pervis est devenu le premier
coureur à s'imposer sur la piste du
vélodrome nationale reste à confirmer
ses promesses dans un mois à cali c'est
un équipement en tout cas très
impressionnant et puis si vous voulez le
découvrir vers ce vélodrome il ya des
journées portes ouvertes qui auront lieu
ce samedi et dimanche et donc si vous
voulez voir du cyclisme sur piste ou
encore du bmx ou des démonstrations
d'autres activités rendez vous entre 9h
et 18h alors ce vélodrome rappelez vous
c'était une promesse présidentielle lors
de la candidature de la france aux jeux
olympiques de 2012 alors la france
n'avait pas obtenu l'organisation de ces
jo mais la construction de la piste
avait été bien actée via un partenariat
public privé alors valérie pécresse
présidente départementale de l'ump
ancien ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche était
l'invité du 7-8 l'actus ce jeudi elle
est revenue sur ce type de partenariat
développé par l'ancienne majorité
est-ce que ce vélodrome c'est d'ores et
déjà un succès ne serait ce que sur le
choix de la structure qui a été fait à
celle d'un partenariat public privé
oui moi je suis très heureuse de cette
inauguration parce que c'est
l'aboutissement des efforts de tous
et puis parce qu'on n'avait pas l'argent
pour le financer à l'époque où la
candidature de paris aux jeux olympiques
a été retoquée et pas l'argent et on a
décidé de manière un peu audacieuse de
faire un partenariat public privé et je
sais qu'aujourd'hui par idéologie la
région
un certain nombre de collectivités de
gauche refusent de financer les
partenariats public privé or là et bien
là ville nouvelle de saint quentin la
région ile de france et l'état ont fait
un magnifique partenariat avec le
secteur privé qui nous permet à moindre
coût d'avoir eu cet équipement et de
l'avoir eu surtout en temps et heure
parce que très souvent vous savez quand
c'est l'état qui finance ou conseillers
collectivités publiques
il ya des retards dans l'achèvement des
travaux le partenariat public privé à ce
marché avec bouygues est un bâtiment
notamment en ile de france et ses vélos
police qui va donc gérer une
exploitation et maintenance du site
pendant 30 ans investissement de 74
millions d'euros 53 millions financé par
l'état la région ile-de-france ans quand
le conseil général et la communauté
d'agglomération
voilà et puis si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur le modèle économique de ce
vélodrome rendez vous jeudi prochain
dans l'émission file echo présentés par
claire cambier un dossier complet
complexe sera consacrée justement à ce
financement est en marge de cette
inauguration du vélodrome il ya ceux qui
ne veulent pas être oubliés ce sont
elles les a signés le centre national du
cyclisme français fait toujours débat
pour certains habitants unis montent à
anthony rech 3,7 millions d'euros c'est
la somme que réclame la société
vélopolis à neuf habitants de montigny
le bretonneux a signé suite alors
recours déposé en 2010 contre le permis
de construire du vélodrome et le plan
local d'urbanisme
certains animaux atteints ont récemment
arrêté leur combat clairement demandé 3
7 millions d'euros à neuf personnes neuf
citoyens qui ont simplement déposé un
recours contre le permis de construire
contrôle p lus c'est vraiment une
manoeuvre d'intimidation
d'ailleurs trois d'entre eux n'ont pas
supporté la pression que suppose cette
intimidation et donc se sont retirés
initialement prévue le 21 janvier
l'audience a pour l'instant été reporté
selon l'association le financement du
projet risque de mettre en difficulté
financière la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce que le
vélodrome a été fait dans le cadre d'un
partenariat public privé
donc qui est un gouffre financier qui
était très à la mode il ya quelques
années sur lequel toutes les
collectivités territoriales sont en
train de revenir parce que c'est une
façon d'avoir de l'argent rapidement
mais qui à long terme est vraiment
quelque chose qui va en fait amputer
leurs finances pour les assigner de
montigny les millions investis dans le
vélodrome ont empêché la réalisation
d'autres projets ils inaugureront
symboliquement une non piste cyclabe au
bord de la nationale 10 sur la commune
de trappes ce samedi 1er février
nous allons maintenant parler sécurité
pas de mieux dans le ciel de la
délinquance dans les yvelines un rapport
sur l'action de la sécurité 2013
elle vient d'être présenté en préfecture
73 1464 c'est le nombre précis de faits
constatés parmi ces faits a noté une
augmentation des cambriolages + 14 %
les escroqueries et les infractions
économiques ont fui les financières ont
également progressé de près de 14%
mitigé c'est ainsi que le préfet a
qualifié le bilan sécurité 2013 dans le
département des yvelines
le point noir ce sont les cambriolages
en progression de 14%
cette augmentation était principalement
concentrée sur le premier semestre et un
peu mois sur second semestre ce qui
pourrait laisser croire que les efforts
que nous avons faits à la matière
commencent à porter leurs fruits mais
nous verrons évidemment encore là 2014
si c'est le cas il y a trois types de
cambrioleurs un tiers des cambrioleurs
sont le fait
résident du département un tiers de
cambrioleurs réside dans la région
ile-de-france d'un tiers de cambrioleurs
viennent de plus loin et plus
particulièrement
pour nombre d'entre eux d'un certain
nombre de pays d'europe centrale
en parallèle de ces chiffres des taux
d'élucidation qui augmente avec de
nouveaux moyens de coordination des
groupes d' enquêtes professionnelles ont
par exemple été constitué j'ai voulu
spécialisé mois des équipes
la police nationale a fait exactement la
même chose des équipes de lutte contre
les cambriolages des enquêteurs qui
travaillent exclusivement sur ces
phénomènes avec de bons résultats et
finalement lorsque vous voyez ce qui est
indicateur d'activité des services en
gendarmerie
nous avons une hausse des taux
d'élucidation nous avons 15 % de faits
élucidés en plus les atteintes aux biens
nous avons une hausse de l'ordre de 2%
d'une taux d'élucidation associé à cela
une réponse judiciaire plus forte
les comparutions immédiates sont en
augmentation en 2013 de 15%
nous en faisons environ six par jour
ouvrable au parquet au tribunal de
versailles ce qui est un chiffre assez
élevé ce qui correspond à la volonté de
réprimer rapidement et fermement les
comportements les plus graves mais aussi
les plus simples tous les cambrioleurs
majeurs sont déférés devant très bien la
comparution immédiate
tous les temps leurs mineurs sont
déférés devant le juge pour enfants
40% des interpellations se font sur
appel à 17 donc nous continuons à
attirer l'attention des voisins pour
dire si vous constatez quelque chose de
pas normal dans votre voisinage
n'hésitez pas à appeler le 17
à côté des cambriolages qui progresse
l'autre préoccupation ce sont les
violences physiques les conflits de voie
publique et les conflits intrafamiliaux
les escroqueries et les infractions
financières et économiques liés au
développement d'internet sont en
progression de près de 14%
enfin dernière infraction en hausse est
liée cette fois aux stupéfiants entre
2010 et 2013 et les trafics des reventes
ont augmenté 209%
autre point noir soulevé lors de la
présentation de ce rapport les chiffres
de la sécurité routière le nombre
d'accidents est en baisse de 7%
le nombre de blessés en diminution celui
des tués sur la route est stable
toutefois les responsables pointe du
doigt les quinze piétons tués cette
année ils n'étaient que 4 en 2012
ce mercredi soir première réunion de la
communauté de communes de l'ouest
parisien qui regroupe les villes de
plaisir villepreux et clayes-sous-bois
la mère de cette dernière commune
véronique côté millard on le sait n'est
pas favorable à cette intercommunalité
alors est elle présente ce mercredi soir
réponse première réunion ce mercredi
soir de la communauté de communes de
l'ouest parisien regroupant les villes
de plaisir ville preuves et des
clayes-sous-bois un premier conseil
regardez de près car depuis l'annnonce
de la constitution de cette
intercommunalité la ville des caisses en
bois s'y opposent
véronique côté millard la mer était
pourtant bien présente hier soir mais
pour demander le report de cette
première réunion communautaire arguant
du fait que la mairie n'a pas été avisé
assez tôt de la tenue de ce conseil et
quelle n'a pas reçu les différents
comptes rendus des réunions
préparatoires réunions auxquelles la
mairie des clayes-sous-bois ne s'est
d'ailleurs jamais présenté une demande
de report rejetée par l'assemblée
constituante
véronique côté millard quitte alors la
séance mais promet d'envoyer des
conseillers communautaires
on comprendrait bien dans la situation
actuelle la discussion n'est pas n'est
plus envisagé mais nous nommerons
cependant nous nos neuf conseillers
communautaires pour un délai maximum de
deux mois peut-être qu'ils auront eu le
temps encore de si j'ai une fois la
séance s'est poursuivie avec l'élection
du président de la communauté de
communes la mère de plaisir a été élu à
l'unanimité comme berger
coleman berger regarder l'avenir de
plusieurs mois de petit chien de lait
provient on n'est pas là pour faire ce
genre de guéguerres intestines on sait
même pas si demain nous serons là
puisque les élections municipales donc
écouter soyaux calme et en signe
d'ouverture malgré son absence véronique
côté millard a été élue vice-présidente
la communauté de communes de l'ouest
parisien devrait au complet en principe
se réunir en mars prochain pour voter
son budget une étape importante qui
devrait donner lieu à de nouvelles
passes d'armes oral entre les maires de
ces trois communes et économie
maintenant avec en vue une entreprise
l'économie sociale et solidaire
implantée à trappes ici à l'accès à
l'emploi est le maître mot chaque
salarié signe un contrat d'insertion
clark en biais et elodie mois nous
dresse un bilan un an après l'ouverture
de l'entreprise
l'association on vit à trappes propose
depuis fin 2012 des appareils
électroménagers rénové est garanti les
clients n'ont habituellement accès qu'à
ce magasin mais lundi une partie des
financeurs de l'association étaient
invités à visiter l'arrière boutique
envie récupère ses machines usagées et
les répare et pour cela elle emploie
aujourd'hui une vingtaine de personnes
dont deux emplois d'avenir et 16 cdi cdd
y ce sont des contrats à durée
déterminée d'insertion
on embauche une personne pour une durée
de quatre mois ces contrats là sont
renouvelables jusqu'à une période
maximum de deux ans le principe pour
nous et pas d'embauché
de manière durable et définitive les
personnes que maintenant pour
l'insertion mais c'est de les
accompagner
professionnellement et socialement de
leur donner des outils pour trouver un
emploi durable
à la sortie de l'entreprise le turn over
est donc important mais 50% des salariés
arrivent à se réinsérer via un autre
emploi ou une formation
professionnalisante
à l'initiative de cette visite ile de
france active un réseau d'associations
de financement solidaire qui a prêté à
andy soit 7000 euros les investisseurs
surtout publics restent nombreux la
région a délivré de son côté une
subvention de 120 mille euros son budget
annuel pour ce secteur est de 12
millions alors les entreprises
d'économie sociale et solidaire ne
peuvent elles survivre sans aide
elles reçoivent moins dead que ce que
reçoivent les entreprises françaises de
l'économie dit classique si vous prenez
p as à l'entreprise peugeot
ils ont reçu plus de dette que n'importe
qui dans ce pays et pourtant
et ça ne leur empêche pas de s'écrouler
donc les entreprises d'insertion les
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire sont pas les mieux lotis et
arrive à presque mieux s'en sortir
donc c'est un faux débat tout le monde
est subventionnée dans ce pays
l'association en vie harry va
s'autofinancer à 60%
elle espère atteindre les 100% d'ici
trois ans direction maintenant montigny
le bretonneux au sein de l'espace saint
quentin alors vous souvenez très
certainement de l'ancien cinéma gaumont
et bien ces salles vont bientôt renaître
en accueillant un bowling celui qui
était auparavant implantée dans le
centre commercial sqy ouest
le point avec anthony rech
les quinze pistes sont déjà installés
débuté en octobre dernier les travaux du
nouveau bullingdon forme ici à l'espace
central et à la future salle de réunion
ouverte aux entreprises et aux
associations
après l'épisode décoration finale pour
l'instant on a terminé tout ce qui était
ventilation installation d
de la climatisation
tout est à mettre en route on a déjà
fait les sanitaires auparavant implanté
au centre commercial sqy ouest
le bowling s'apprête à s'installer dans
l'ancien complexe de six salles de
cinéma il monte un sur près de 2000 m²
il ya deux trois salariés de bowling
star qui était déjà à salariés de
l'ancien établissement qui vont
reprendre pour le reste sera de
l'embauché locale
l'entrée principale donnera sur lequel
françois truffaut pour ceux qui se
souviennent cette entrée correspondre à
l'une des anciennes sorties proche de la
médiathèque du canal il y aura également
des billards pour les amateurs le
bowling devrait ouvrir ses portes fin
février alors qu n'est pas du tout le
cinéma en effet ça a bien changé allez
on termine 7,8 actu avec un sourire
plutôt des souris a même beaucoup de
voix se des jeunes bambins qui ont
participé au concours du plus beau bébé
cadum un concours créé en 1925 remis au
goût du jour en 2007 40000 tout jeunes
participants 12 finalistes parmi eux un
heavy noah timothée olivet maniscalco et
patrick avec disney ont suivi cette
finale depuis 1925 de l'eca d'hommes
élit chaque année son plus beau tout
petit l'élection remise au goût du jour
en 2007 le désigne désormais parmi
quarante mille bébés inscrire en ligne
suite au vote sur internet 12 bambins
sont sélectionnés pour la finale dont le
petit timothée du chenet qui se
présentait avec ses parents sur la scène
de l'elysée biarritz apparaît en fait
c'est des amis de lucie qui avait déjà
fait ce genre de concours et qui l'ont
mis dans le
enfin que lui en donner envie en tout
cas d'y participer et donc
donc voilà on a tenté notre chance et de
puits depuis qu'il a 6 mois en fait tous
les mois on essaye et on n'avait jamais
eu une chance jusqu'à maintenant et puis
on a eu le top 50 en décembre et top 5
et puis bébé tourner une fois qu'on a eu
énormément de chance beaucoup de chance
peut-être mais il reste une dernière
étape à franchir pour timothée face à
lui les internautes qui pouvait voter en
suivant la cérémonie en ligne et un jury
composé de célébrités dont la chanteuse
préférée des tout petits génies comme
critère celui qui était éveillée celui
qui qui était très indépendant bon bah
j'en avais vu j'en avais mis un autre
mais c'est pas grave cette petite fille
était très très mignonne aussi
ressemblait bien à bébé cadum
c'est en effet la petite clara 17 mois
qui a su séduire les votants et remporte
ce concours 2014 avec tout de même six
mille euros offerts emplacement sur un
livret a
qu'elle pourra toucher à ses 18 ans ça
valait bien une petite chance
là
voilà c'était un lapin qui avance et
indémodable chantal goya se sentent 8
l'actuel terminé merci de votre
attention le journal d'information
revient en direct lundi dès 18h tout de
suite vous retrouvez le 7-8 week-end
présenté par olivier maniscalco bon week
end